[Música]
Como irritar o jogador de LoL isso ainda
vai acontecer ou não
[Música]
Bom dia pessoal primeiro vídeo do ano
aqui neste canal Eu só liguei a câmera
não sei o que é que vou fazer mas vou
acompanhar o meu dia
O que é que tens a dizer não tem nada a
dizer porquê porque é um cão
vamos fazer o meu treino vamos fazer a
minha comidinha vou editar vídeo para o
canal de jogos sim para quem não sabe eu
tenho um canal de jogos Dark frame 2.0
vocês também perguntam muito pelo
jogador de LoL portanto hoje vou ligar
ao pi a perguntar quando é que ele vem
cá a casa eu tenho andado um pouco
triste comigo porque o Natal estragou
completamente a minha dieta eu achei que
não ia comer assim tanto e comi eu odeio
e comi Ah seis fatias de um bom Rei
então ya Acabei por engordar 6 kg e até
agora ainda não consegui recuperar
recuperei dois quilinhos só estou cheio
de açúcar na veia ainda ai eu não sei o
que tem me ajudado ele dá motivação ele
diz ah uau e eu sei que tem que ir
treinar tem que tirar a minha motivação
do cu porque hoje está difícil mas vamos
lá tomar o pré-treino pessoal café e
ainda vamos tomar aquele Expresso Ah
pois é oh quase me esqueci isto parece
que não foi programado para ouvir chegou
aqui em casa pessoal esta máquina de
café da marca
ibro e eles enfiaram aqui uma mala
secreta que é isto é pesado não tão
pesado como eu mas é pesado é
aparentemente esta máquina é compatível
três cafés ai Faz o café em pó também
isto isto faz os cafés todos
eu lá toda cromada Espero que não seja
gasoso tá cara tem um monte de
coisas aqui dentro onde é suposto levar
a água mas vamos ver isto
ah entendi entendi aqui diz que é só
colocar água e está a funcionar também
viu isto para nós não faço ideia do que
seja mas parece uma uma chata este é o
acessório onde leva as cápsulas todas na
Expresso Nescafé Dolce Gusto tudo
[Música]
toma aí já entendi para que que isto
serve isto para deixar os cápsulas aqui
organizadas ai meu pré-treino aqui Como
podem ver deixei cair o café todo
Vamos lá fazer café
obviamente que este não é para beber né
Vocês estão malucos esta aqui era só
para testar a água e limpar um pouco a
máquina né o próximo eu já vou beber os
dois modos funcionam bem Olha aí o que é
que eles me enviaram mais eles enviaram
esta malinha basicamente isto é uma
máquina de café portátil ui ui posso
levar isto para praia Vocês estão a
brincar
é aqui pois tenho que levar primeiro
Vai um cafezinho Não mano agora é
portátil mano um pouquinho a carregar
Então vamos testar diretamente da tomada
está a nossa máquina de café portátil
olha
ninguém foi na temperatura porque ele
está frio hora do treino
[Música]
eu já tinha feito algumas lives Tik Tok
continuo ali na passadeira a correr e
muitas vezes quando eu corro 18 a
máquina Buga e começa a aparecer
999999 em todos os dígitos tanto na
velocidade como na elevação em tudo e eu
pensei que tinha de comprar uma
passadeira nova mas descobri há pouco
tempo que o problema era do cabo de
alimentação que era de outros produtos
que eu tenho aqui em casa então não
estava a dar Power suficiente para
passadeira Então já coloquei o cabo
certo funciona perfeita agora eu até
fazer um treino de uma musculação hoje
mas ainda me dói muito os músculos do
treinamento anterior então eu vou saltar
um pouco o treino se calhar eu vou dar
uns Socorro Imaginário que este saque é
o caso eu vou lhe bater
[Música]
gostosa acabou o treino pessoal
entretanto eu vou-vos passar aí algumas
imagens do dia de ontem passaram uns
amigos meus e que estamos comida
asiática foi a minha despedida de
açúcares porque hoje oficialmente
começou a dieta outra vez e os treinos
[Aplausos]
aqui com o Miguel Andrade Alex MP Street
na área Olá boa noite boa tarde não sei
onde é que eles estão a ver se é do
Brasil sei lá do Japão é mais cedo no
Japão lá em Japão olha Sushi do goma
chegaste na hora certa atenção Isso tudo
foi patrocinado pelo nosso amigo Miguel
[Aplausos]
São portugueses mas fica para a próxima
por dentro grande quanto maior o melhor
não é Miguel Você sempre foi duas
eu também gosto de coisas grandes
não não não não não combinado
pessoal está a acontecer aqui um
problema não conseguimos dominar a Fera
vamos falar aqui um pequeno resumo do
que é que nós temos aqui
umas horas estranhas asiáticas
Marshmallows supostamente temos aqui
está o quê
Isto é das melhores vidas que eu já
experimentei Doctor papers só que esta
aqui é tipo mais meio com café meio
leite não é tipo se muda mais cremosa eu
não sei explicar isso é chupa
laranja vocês comam análise agora no
Inverno por causa da da constipação não
seja de rainha mas olha cá
eu como a noite
com um gajo duvido que mostra juro claro
eu adoro eu não gosto de dar isto ao
normal mas assim juro que é muito melhor
e isto é o quê Ah esta aqui é bastante
conhecida dos gamers
muito
eu tenho que dormir
eu já provei o original
que que nós temos aqui também Cheetos
com Cheetos de frango temos uns puffs
que vocês já viram também no Tik Tok da
Ana porque ela já revelou uma goma
gigante
isso é isto Só que assim em Barras eu
estou curioso Bora eu vou começar já
Limpo também
Ai que bom
não é bom o que com um gajo é muito
estranho
eu adorei eu adoro esse gajo não é bom
mas é estranho não é estranho só
é bom e é mal ao mesmo tempo Acho que
era melhor
leite
daquela pirâmide da alimentação tirar um
estatualizar não bebo leite só quando
são pequenininho
não é bom é muito bom
olha o meu nunca me obrigou a nada
mas eu não como muitos doces sou mais
salgadinhos croquete inscrições
na França
esta tartaruga ficaram lá dois dias
sozinhos no kraftadinha
não posso brincar
5 segundos no chão esta é maravilhosa
Essa é maravilhosa
eu quero que vocês vejam a diferença
desta embalagem é comparação à bosta que
vem dentro
olha para isto
calma Veja uma imagem
vejam que foi dentro estou a ver aqui
este tópico em cima
essa boca
queimar pensava que sabia
é muito pesado
este aqui nós já provamos também a
caminho de casa então não Vamos provar
agora é não é frango uma cera tipo pizza
estes são os melhores Cheetos pessoal se
vocês encontrarem em alguma loja comprem
experimentem Cheetos de frango aqui diz
basicamente batata da palavra
que isso poderoso
é não sei explicar É sério pessoal
experimentem Se estiverem a oportunidade
mas não é isto
[Risadas]
esta bolinha aqui eu vou no Gunga
normal
e vocês começarem toda a pequenininha
mas depois tipo pessoas que tinha saia
ao contrário mental
[Risadas]
[Música]
eu não sou muito adepto de café com
leite
[Aplausos]
e Disseste que era não vou não usar
proteção e ele disse que toma
entretanto Já se passaram algumas horas
tive aqui editar este vídeo que vai sair
no canal secundário Dark frame 2.0 mas
agora pessoal hora da verdade vou ligar
o pi e vamos ver a opinião dele se ele
quer voltar a filmar ou como é que está
o jogador logo se não quer se ele vem
aqui em casa vamos ver
alô
tá sem vídeo Então o que é que estás a
fazer
tropa Lucas
[Música]
quero fazer uma pergunta
tá muita gente a pedir Como irritar o
jogador de LoL isso ainda vai acontecer
ou não
estamos em fevereiro
[Música]
pessoal Lupita a dizer que não não vai
haver acabou a série
[Música]
meio vazio será então o copo tá meio
cheio ou meio vazio o copo para ti tá
mais cheio
desses enigmas
pronto mas quando é que vem cá
só na segunda semana
a gente pode trompai segunda semana tá
Yah pi vem cá quatro dias se calhar
ainda joga qualquer coisa
como é que vai meter a jogar
o pietramado ele deixou isto em aberto
agora eu não sei se ele quer fazer se
não quero fazer não pareceu que ele
tinha muita vontade mas de qualquer
forma ele vem cá já o convidei ele
aceitou ele até pode nem querer fazer o
vídeo mas não importa basta ele começar
a jogar o logo basta ele Abrir o
aplicativo do jogo eu vou estar lá com a
câmera então vocês também têm com
convencer a jogar logo se paramem o pi
como mensagens passem lá na Live dele
vão lá Twitch dele vão ao Instagram ou
pi por favor por obséquio não queres por
gentileza faltar a jogar LOL não falem
Como irritar jogador de LoL digam só pi
não pudesse jogar bolas experimentar os
EAD
experimentar o o rabo dormes no no
caso sei lá não sei convenção a jogar
logo o pessoal e depois passa o meu
trabalho